je suis très intersectionnelle
l'intersectionnalité je comprends même
pas pourquoi ça suscite des cris
d'orfray comme on en entend beaucoup
[Musique]
et bien je suis toute prête j'attends ça
avec curiosité
[Musique]
oui Alice Coffin elle a pas tort dans ce
qu'elle dit là c'est vrai c'est à dire
que elle elle dépeint un monde où les
hommes
conservent la parole le pouvoir etc et
d'autre part elle dit qu'elle est bien
avec des copines voilà des copines
féministes moi j'ai ressenti très très
bien cela dans les années 70 plutôt 70
80 au moment du mouvement de libération
des femmes Alice Coffin bien plus tard
là on est dans les dans ces dernières
années elle le dit et je comprends bien
cette parole alors éliminer les hommes
de la bibliothèque non absolument pas
moi je revendique les oeuvres des hommes
je les ai lu je m'en suis appréhier bon
c'est ma bibliothèque dans tous les
vocabres qu'on emploie aujourd'hui je
suis très intersectionnelle
l'intersectionnalité je comprends même
pas pourquoi ça suscite des cris
d'orfray comme on en entend beaucoup
parce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire croiser plusieurs variables
ensemble et bien on a toujours nous les
féministes on a toujours dit il y a le
genre il y a le social je me revendique
comme
universalisme avec la présence des deux
sexes égaux et libres voilà
[Musique]
être femme ce n'est pas une donnée
naturelle
c'est le résultat d'une histoire il y a
pas un destin biologique psychologique
qui définissent la femme en tant que
telle c'est une histoire qu'il a faite
d'abord l'histoire de la civilisation
qui aboutit à son statut actuel et
d'autre part pour chaque femme
particulière c'est l'histoire de sa vie
en particulier c'est l'histoire de son
enfant qu'il a détermine comme femme qui
crée en elle quelque chose qui n'est pas
du tout une donnée une essence qui crée
en elle ce qu'on appelait quelquefois
l'éternel féminin la féminité
Simone de Beauvoir pour moi cette femme
est pas pour moi et pour beaucoup
d'autres elle a énormément compté
beaucoup beaucoup pourquoi
perso sa vie les choix qu'elle a fait
dans sa vie c'est-à-dire écrire créer
vivre librement sa sexualité et son
amour elle a eu un amour fondamental
toute sa vie pour ça
elle a eu d'autres amours dans sa vie
bien sûr et puis elle conduisait moi
j'admirais ça beaucoup elle était au
volant de sa voiture elle parcourait la
France et le monde oui c'est une figure
de femme libre et puis évidemment par
son œuvre le Deuxième Sexe 1949
j'étais étudiante à ce moment-là on ne
naît pas femme on le devient et le
Deuxième Sexe demeure
toujours à des textes absolument
fondamentaux dans l'histoire de la
pensée féministe parce que il faut bien
voir que le féminisme c'est à la fois
une action et une pensée c'est une
manière de voir le monde autrement en y
introduisant la différence des sexes
construite justement par la culture et
par l'histoire
[Musique]
la grande nouveauté de la guerre
Première Guerre mondiale c'est l'arrivée
des femmes dans des secteurs où il
n'était pas jusque là la métallurgie car
il y avait une résistance ouvrière dont
on n'a pas parlé qui a des raisons très
variables
contre l'entrée des formes dans certains
secteurs virils alors les hommes et bien
parce que dès que les hommes redoutent
la concurrence des femmes parce que ça
signifie baisse des salaires
qui est cette personne c'est comme si
j'étais une autre personne je ne me
reconnais pas ça ne se faisait pas du
tout dans ma génération on n'allait pas
à la télé la télévision faisant appel à
nous les historiens les intellectuels
c'était quand même très très rare très
très peu fréquent l'intérêt pour le
monde ouvrier moi j'étais étudiante dans
les années 50 la France était en
reconstruction
l'industrialisation c'était absolument
capital le monde ouvrier c'était
essentiel en même temps les ouvriers
c'était la figure de l'injustice voilà
il y avait ça et la figure de l'Autre la
figure du pauvre le pauvre qui m'avait
tellement préoccupé dans ma jeunesse
chrétienne c'était les ouvriers voilà la
grande différence entre cette époque et
la nôtre aujourd'hui maintenant
c'est que le monde ouvrier était en
croissance il y avait un développement
du monde ouvrier qui évidemment n'existe
plus du tout maintenant la classe
ouvrière elle disparaît au fond elle
disparaît progressivement il y en a
encore faut quand même pas exagéré mais
là c'était le monde de l'avenir et
suivre les ouvriers c'était suivre la
voie d'avenir
[Musique]
tomber elle est si fragile est une femme
libérée tu sais c'est pas si facile ne
la laisse pas tomber elle est si fragile
est une femme libérée tu sais c'est pas
si facile ne la laisse pas oui la
conquête de la liberté a été un long
combat des femmes et ça le demeure
aujourd'hui mes parents étaient très
égalitaires en ce qui me concerne mon
père était un homme qui me qui aurait
voulu un garçon qui bon mais qui m'a
traité comme un garçon voilà et qui me
disait il faut que tu sois autonome
libre que tu gagnes ta vie et surtout
ne te marie pas trop vite ne te mets pas
trop tôt un homme sur le dos disait-il
en riant donc il y avait dans mon milieu
familial à la fois des modèles de femmes
dominées qui auraient voulu autre chose
ma mère et une parole masculine c'est
très important quand même une parole
masculine parce que les hommes ont
avaient le pouvoir ça va donner
l'impulsion ça m'a donné des ailes pour
faire ce que je voulais
[Musique]
au départ il faut bien dire que la très
brillante école française d'histoire
dont nous sommes tous et toutes les
enfants ne se posaient pas beaucoup la
question du rapport des sexes dans
l'histoire alors je pense qu'ils sont
intéressés parce que nous avons fait
surpris peut-être de la qualité enfin
bon à leurs yeux d'éruditions qu'il peut
y avoir
c'est une certaine manière je pense
qu'ils vont l'incorporer mais ça sera
peut-être difficile parce que l'histoire
reste tout de même une discipline très
masculine en France notamment
[Musique]
l'histoire a été elle a été sexiste bien
sûr elle a été écrite par les hommes
elle a été enseignée par les hommes
quand je suis entré comme assistante à
la Sorbonne dans les années 1960 grâce à
Ernest la brousse j'étais la seule
il y avait il y avait j'étais la seule
femme si il y avait une autre femme en
histoire ancienne mademoiselle Demougeot
je me souviens malgré tout l'histoire
est une discipline construite par les
hommes et par conséquent accès sur le
public c'est à dire l'espace public le
pouvoir politique
les créations masculines bien sûr
l'histoire raconte les hommes et ne
parle pas des femmes
[Musique]
j'aurais bien voulu avoir ma retraite
maintenant 60 ans vous savez quand on
travaille tant d'années dans des usines
et faire le ménage et s'occuper des
gosses et pour mes vieux jours je
voudrais bien encore être heureux avec
mon mari
si peu qu'on a encore à vivre
se distraire un petit peu voyager un peu
et voilà le gouvernement il veut pas
nous donner à 60 ans
alors jusqu'à 65 ans je ne crois pas que
je pourrais travailler
j'avais pris plus en plus
cette femme émouvante
dit bien la souffrance
d'un monde qui est très dur du point de
vue du travail et par conséquent
l'aspiration à la retraite comme elle
dit j'aimerais bien encore voyager
j'aimerais bien vivre encore un peu avec
mon mari les hommes et les femmes ne
sont pas égaux dans la question des
retraites les femmes gagne moins que les
hommes même à travailler égal le salaire
n'est pas égal il y a toujours à l'heure
actuelle ça varie les appréciations
entre 12 autour de 12% de différence qui
est énorme ce qui est énorme et qui est
moins qu'autrefois mais deuxièmement il
y a une autre raison qui est peut-être
encore bien plus fondamental c'est
qu'elles ne font pas les mêmes métiers
voilà
elles font des métiers
féminiser comme on dit qui sont moins
valorisés moins bien payées là par
exemple regarder le secteur des soins le
secteur des soins est féminisé très
largement dans les hôpitaux et ailleurs
à la maison aussi et ce sont des métiers
qui sont pas bien payés et ça quand on
regarde les chiffres des retraites des
femmes on se dit mon dieu
[Musique]
je chercherai avec vous les majorités
les plus larges
sans que personne
est à renoncer à ce qu'il est là
vraiment on est dans un système
incroyablement monarchie que regarder le
parcours de Madame de Pompadour regardez
le parcours des guides cresson il y a un
parallélisme certain j'ai entendu des
députés derrière moi dire elle est pas
mal foutue etc crois-tu qu'elle a un
slip je me suis retourné pour leur
demander si eux ils en avaient un
misogyne
je vois bien chez elle en train de faire
le ménage ou s'occuper de ses enfants
voilà cette pauvre Edith Cresson et elle
elle a subit là à la fois de la part de
l'Assemblée nationale de la part de
l'opinion publique des hommes etc et de
son propre parti qui ne la soutenait pas
la comparaison avec la Pompadour dire
qu'elle était une favorite de Mitterrand
que c'est pour ça qu'elle était au
pouvoir c'est incroyable
misogynie qui pouvait régner dans ces
années-là qui sont des années de gauche
quand même
la gauche franchement ne donne pas non
plus une bonne image d'elle-même à ce
propos je pense qu'il y a eu des progrès
tout de même je pense que ça serait plus
possible maintenant et à la limite voir
la première ministre c'est la deuxième
expérience de Première ministre avec
Elisabeth borde c'est tout autre chose
personne ne fait plus maintenant il me
semble du moins de commentaires sur son
physique sur la manière dont elle est
habillée etc etc et elle-même a l'air
tout à fait décontracté de ce point de
vue là faut pas oublier que cette femme
a fait Polytechnique qu'elle a donc été
aussi dans un milieu très masculin elle
connaît tout ça et là il me semble qu'il
y a un progrès il y a un progrès qui me
réjouit
avant je partais pas le voile je me suis
reconvertie donc j'ai vu qu'à
l'université story autorisée je trouve
que c'est une bonne chose chacun a sa
culture sa religion on laisse bien les
les gens venir en casquette rentrer dans
la classe en casquette et le professeur
ne leur dit pas de l'enlever donc
pourquoi leur dire d'enlever le voile je
voudrais dire d'abord le voile c'est un
signe de domination masculine depuis
toujours
le premier qu'il aurait introduit c'est
Cyrus Legrand Perse
600 ans avant Jésus-Christ qui aurait
imposé le voile aux femmes pour la
chasteté pour vraiment que le corps des
femmes ne troublent pas les hommes et ça
a été reproduit par les chrétiens Saint
Paul les femmes auront la tête couverte
dans les assemblées et elle ne parleront
pas et deux choses pas de visage
pas de cheveux surtout pas de cheveux et
pas de parole bon et puis repris par les
religieux successives évidemment par
l'Islam aujourd'hui c'est l'islam qui
aujourd'hui est le plus porteur de voile
je me réjouis
que il y ait une loi qui interdisent les
signes religieux à l'école parce que je
pense que la laïcité c'est un appui pour
les femmes
laïcité féminisme ça marche ensemble
dans l'espace public que on s'habille
comme on veut si une femme je vais le
regretter pour ma part et prouve le
besoin de se mettre à voir sur la tête
je vais essayer de lui dire que elle a
peut-être pas raison de le faire je vais
pas lui interdire au nom de quoi est-ce
que je vais interdirais certainement pas
et une femme on a beaucoup parlé de ça
des femmes qui accompagnent leurs
enfants dans les sorties à l'école et
qui et qui sont voilées est-ce qu'il
faut les chasser non bien entendu non
pas donc ma position elle est absolument
contre le voile dans son principe contre
le discours sur le voile mais il est
évidemment plus tolérant et plus
compréhensive vis-à-vis des femmes qui
portent le voile
[Musique]
puis la misogynie est intéressante aussi
c'est parce que c'est de la misogynie il
faut être misogyne il faut aimer les
femmes mettre misogynes savoir mettre
les femmes à leur place justement sur
une trône ça les adorer mais quand on a
fini les adorer il faut qu'elle [__]
la paix
la femme tu es la plus grande artiste
parce qu'elle fait un objet
extraordinaire c'est pour ça qu'il y a
pas de femme
et pas de femmes vraiment
qui va sortir de moi c'est
extraordinaire je comprends je comprends
pas les femmes qui ont pas le sens
maternelle
ces propos sont étonnants mais pas
surprenant voilà un homme qui dit ce que
on a pensé et écrit dit pendant des
siècles c'est à dire
les femmes c'est la maternité la
maternité est une grande chose voilà
mais quelle j'y reste c'est ça leur part
et pour le reste de nous emmerde pas
voilà et elles sont pas créatrices elles
n'ont pas intervenir dans la création
véritablement qu'elle reste à leur place
il aurait dû ajouter cet homme là sous
le contrôle des hommes sous le contrôle
des hommes peut-être qu'il ne le dit pas
peut-être qu'il y a un progrès j'en sais
rien mais si on allait au XIXe siècle le
Code civil Napoléon le fameux code
Napoléon c'est un monument du patriarcat
c'est l'homme qui est le chef de famille
le père de famille
et les femmes n'ont aucun droit sur les
biens ni sur les enfants ni sur le choix
de la résidence sur rien
[Musique]
comment ça se passait j'y serai pas allé
parce que j'ai été démoli pour toujours
chez 85 ans mais je suis faible par
certains côtés je suis fragile
exactement
parce que la guerre de 14 c'était une
épreuve
démentielle mais pas d'autres mots
à l'autre et alors
j'ai compris dans ce que ça pouvait être
que l'inhumanité
mon père avait fait la guerre 14-18
très jeune il avait gardé de la de la
guerre
un souvenir terrible
il ne voulait d'ailleurs pas en parler
il commençait quelques phrases et puis
il me disait de me parle plus de ça et
notamment il y a un souvenir qu'il a
évoqué pour moi quand même et qui qui
m'est restait beaucoup
le souvenir des tranchées justement il y
a sa mitraille de tous les côtés et il y
a un officier qui est tué sous ses yeux
pratiquement et il me disait j'avais eu
un problème avec cette officier il a été
tué et j'ai ri
et il a ajouté tout de suite et il se
révoltait contre lui-même d'avoir pensé
ça il disait de me parle plus de ça ne
me parle plus de ça donc la guerre 14-18
elle est là mais on en parle pas et
quand on en parle c'est comme quelque
chose de de terrible qui qui vous
transforme vous-même au point que quand
on en est sorti on ne comprend plus ce
qu'on a pu sentir et dire à ce moment là
[Musique]
avant l'aube s'anime tout le peuple des
manutentionnaires avec leur diable et
les petits acheteurs des marchés
[Musique]
et ce sont les scènes toujours
renouvelées des marchandages et le
spectacle tente au mouvementé tant au
paisible de tout un monde un monde de
travail qui se détend dans la chaleur
bienveillante du bistrot
le trou pied à ses exigences tout comme
la petite sœur des pauvres dans cette
course matinale à la nourriture
[Musique]
vers 9h c'est au tour des ménagères
tandis que pour compléter leur maigre
ressources d'un bleu vieillard récupère
de quoi faire une soupe
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup ce spectacle des Halles
que j'ai bien connu nous habitions rue
Greneta la rue Greneta coupe la rue
Saint-Denis à deux pas des Halles et
c'était un monde populaire
populaire et en même temps gay on
chantait et aux rillettes on
s'apostrophère beaucoup et dans ce
quartier qui est le quartier du Sentier
il y avait beaucoup de petites fabriques
textiles et c'était généralement une
main d'oeuvre jeune des jeunes filles et
elle chantait elle chantait elle dansait
moi je me disais mais c'est drôle c'est
drôle on s'amuse bien
je trouvais ça très drôle et dès que
l'on rentrait
l'été surtout l'été 36 l'été qui a suivi
j'étais chez ma grand-mère et là il y
avait
battante qui était une dame angevine de
province et alors là c'était beaucoup
plus réactionnaire c'était ses ouvriers
ces ouvriers quoi qui vont à la plage
maintenant et on va pas pouvoir être
tranquille rendez-vous compte et ma
prise de conscience sociale a été un
petit peu autour du Front populaire vu
comme quelque chose de gai et de festifs
d'un côté mais ça a été pour moi quelque
chose d'inoubliable
[Musique]
les soviettes qui encerclent Budapest
répare mécaniquement une répression
massive ces chars 4500 et 20 divisions
écraseront les Hongrois attaquons leur
capitale au moment même où Moscou parle
de négociation et annoncent l'évacuation
de ces troupes
[Musique]
le monde entier se révolte contre cette
duplicité et ses mœux de la tragédie
hongroise
56 à achevé enfin moi en ce qui me
concerne des
proches
de pas du communisme d'ailleurs mais de
l'Union soviétique certainement avoir
été communiste avoir été dans une
cellule communiste non c'est pas un
regret ce que je peux regretter alors là
oui c'est l'aveuglement
comment est-ce que nous avons pu croire
à ce mensonge qui a été
l'Union soviétique pour ma part ça m'a
rendu
probablement plus
sceptique sans doute
plus critique vis-à-vis de moi quand je
pense quelque chose me dit est-ce que
j'ai raison de le penser quand j'ai des
enthousiastes
je fais quand même un pas de côté en me
disant est-ce que j'ai raison de
m'emballer ce qu'il faut pas faire
attention voilà ça m'a rendu aussi
plutôt les rente
comprendre pourquoi les gens pensent ce
qu'il croit voilà c'est une grande
question c'est une question fondamentale
[Musique]
j'aurais bien aimé que Bernard Pivot me
pose une question il l'a fait d'ailleurs
une fois je crois pour l'histoire de la
vie privée
il a sûrement oublié et moi aussi la
plante l'arbre ou l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné
à l'oiseau j'aimerais me réincarner dans
un oiseau je suppose qu'elle d'ailleurs
mais quelque chose qui vole parce que ça
permet de voir le monde ça permet de
s'échapper
ça permet beaucoup de choses d'être un
oiseau oui j'aurais aimé être un oiseau
[Musique]